[Music]
when i was young i liked having little
businesses i you know a lot of kids sell
like lemonade at the end of their street
one point i saw tadpoles i went to a
local pond i captured some tadpoles i
didn't sell any of them but i they were
for sale and then i let them go one
summer at summer camp at boy scout camp
that christian and i both attended don't
bring me it's
well you're here
uh and you were a customer of mine when
i sold candy
i think i basically broke even the the
funny thing is i would make money and
then i would go spend that money on
candy from the like trading post at the
camp you were also very generous i
remember you'd give a lot of it away
so i think i felt very powerful it's not
that you had customers as much as you
had users you know yeah i was at that
time when you're a kid
sugar is like a drug i would have been a
terrible drug dealer
you know how drug dealers just give the
first one and they're like well the
first one's free they get you hooked
also i'm not convinced that what you
were doing was above board oh no i'm sh
well i i wonder what the statute of
limitations is
probably by now hopefully for your kids
for your funny
you're listening to life for short i am
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my candy loving
brother
does that why does that sound gross now
candy loving yeah it sounds like uh
let's just say that about an adult it
sounds a little juvenile
it doesn't sound grosser than that no i
i do love candy
that's gross
i don't know why there's something
it's candy now is like i don't know why
you think it's it's like naughty like i
consider it naughty in in terms of it
being bad for you if that's what you
mean by yeah it's too cutesy
uh yeah naughty is cutesy yeah that's
why yeah i don't use the word naughty
very often that's why conflating
literally like seriously i say it maybe
i ooh i'm being naughty yeah i just say
it jokingly sometimes yeah who that's
that's funny there are two you know that
expression there are two types of people
in this world but there are those that
say use the word naughty seriously
our mom she would say not you're being
naughty yeah don't be naughty oh she
would say that's
yeah yeah she says it like playfully now
fine when we were kids we were naughty
we didn't get to eat a lot of sweets and
i think that's why i felt so
naughty i felt so dangerous when i went
and bought those i must have been 12 or
13 and i bought those
boxes of candy wholesale i thought it
was so because i was like just at the
age where i i was first i it hadn't been
very long where i was able to buy my own
candy
which was remember that when you're like
so excited it was so it was such a
thrill
soda i remember that was exciting
to be able to go to a soda machine oh my
god it's so cool once i was able to
acquire money i i just wanted to do it
any way i could um so i had these little
uh businesses that you were a little
entrepreneur but i wonder why that
didn't stick oh because now it's i'm
terrible with money i know yeah and i
don't have to tell me
well i'm telling the audience too um
you're right that there was no there's
no remnants of like that entrepreneurial
spirit that i had as a kid had a tough
time i did your eyebrows fast
i gave it like a running
entrepreneurial yeah i did like a
running
running start to it uh entrepreneurial
that's a tough word entrepreneur so by
contrast our guest today is an excellent
adult entrepreneur yes that's right and
i
i'm curiou i was so curious how what her
roots were um in terms of you know how
she came to be interested in that are
you interested in are you just like
money
me no one how does one become an
entrepreneur um i mean what's the route
that they just i think it depends that's
true i think business well we'll see how
the interview goes but
uh
according to our guest today barbara
corcoran oh right yeah i didn't say her
name sorry you were setting me up she uh
she's interested in the reason she loves
business is uh the people and making and
developing relationships with people so
i think i'm sure some people go into
business
for just for the money so they can drive
fancy cars but uh so i think it all
depends mark cuban uh with whom she does
the show shark tank he seems like
he he
likes getting things and and he's like a
big kid he strikes me as a yeah he also
seems like he really enjoys being known
yeah
but
nothing wrong with no yeah i like him he
i do too
i think he's
barbara corker and somebody that i
didn't really know because i'm not um
have you ever seen shark tank i've seen
it uh but i
i didn't know the other sharks by name i
think mark cuban's the only the mystery
wonderful i know just because it's
reason this is a funny name it's just
it's crazy i i've seen a bunch of
episodes i like that show i like it too
i just don't know it well enough to know
her to have known her or knew whatever
uh
do i we'll get into it yeah um but if
maybe you do know barbara and maybe you
don't uh but you're about to know her a
little bit better uh so you did this
interview just for some context uh yeah
a couple weeks ago
uh and now
we are
in the throes of
quarantine wherein justin and i are
quarantining together yeah
in connecticut and so this interview is
done a couple weeks ago before this
happened so
that's the reason that you guys don't
mention it at all right um it was before
so last week we did barbara before bill
nye around the same time around the same
time and um but of course bill and i
talked about it a lot more because
barbara uh is not a science gal so for
the next few weeks um the interviews
will be
from uh before now that happened a week
or two ago before the crisis but
um isn't that crazy all of these intros
will be
smack dab in the middle of the crisis
which is from our quarantine from our
core studio
and uh
we're hoping everyone is doing okay and
getting by in this crazy crazy time
we're also hoping to um check in with
some friends uh so we might do
a special episode um
where we just do that we just christian
i'd call some friends and check in and
uh or not or just uh
talk to each other yeah it depends it
depends how we're feeling
we're taking it day by day yeah um
yeah so uh and please as always feel
free to write in to us and tell us how
you're uh making the most of your
quarantine time life is short at
wondering.com uh but for now let's uh
listen to some pre-quarantine chat with
our guest today
the very saucy
i would say
and um
very fun uh entrepreneur right entre yes
obviously entrepreneurial
[ __ ] that's a tough one
yeah entrepreneurial
uh the entrepreneurial
uh take three barbara corcoran coming up
right after this
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i just did a scroll through your twitter
you have such pearls uh of wisdom that
you i have to follow you now on twitter
because
each one of them were so inspiring uh i
i i like this one wait are we recording
now by the way uh probably not okay oh
we are
okay now we should really talk uh
no were you said that like this is not
gonna be part of the show but certainly
this is not entertaining enough to
record uh but you said one what's all
the fuss about you can find love at any
age i got married in my late 30s and
we're still together 30 plus years later
later age is just a number hashtag the
bachelorette
which i
the fans of this show will know that uh
i i love the bachelor do you watch i do
not know i just knew it was a good tag
to put on there oh
self-serving what is that what oh but
you knew that there was an issue that
had it had been talked about that the
bachelorette the next bachelor is going
to be a slightly older than the other
ones yes i had heard that that's all i
knew about the bachelorette but you'd
swear i was a steady fan i would have
thought that reading my tweet oh now i
wish i hadn't asked you because
the next hour of the show
no no it'll be funny actually that you
did that but you did that knowing that
it might it would attract more attention
yeah probably wow likely yeah that's
smart it got your attention it sure did
i i related to it i wanted to talk to
you about it and i meant to watch it but
i haven't well i'm curious what you
think of it it's really fascinating do
you watch your own show no i never do
really
why is that too self-critical
uh about about everything oh i i should
have said that better
oh look at that dress a little short
monday morning quarterbacking you betcha
in a negative way it's terrible
have you ever done yourself no you're
tough on yourself well you know who i
learned that from this racial ray i was
on her show and noticed how natural she
was doing the guess the camera cruising
switch she was in her own kitchen she's
very easy very easy and consistently
easy yeah so i said to her how do you do
that you have no no nervousness at all
she said i never watched myself and i
said that's a great idea i stopped
watching myself that was like eight nine
years ago oh and it helped oh tremendous
because you're more free to be yourself
you're not editing yourself as you speak
well that's interesting one of the
things i love about the bachelor and you
wouldn't know this if you when you
become a big fan you'll know this um
they are so uh hyper aware of themselves
and you like that i do because as an
actor you can then study how people
behave in this different social context
which is
they're um they're performing i mean
they're all
which we all do we all improvise to a
certain extent but um they are i think
hyper
aware of themselves and what i don't
understand is what does that mean in
other words they're acting and they know
they're acting so they are acting more
themselves
or they're performing or hyper aware
meaning who they're supposed to be
naturally who they want people to see
what they want the narrative that they
want to tell about themselves their
writing and their performing it's really
and
oftentimes poorly you know oh poorly
yeah yeah because yeah it's just that
makes them more human i think somebody
makes you buy in a little more it would
make me buy in well it reveals truths
about them too that i think is really
that's the stuff that i think is really
interesting what what you know that says
a lot about a person what they want
people to think of them you've got to
dress in a gown and get on that show
i can't see me yeah i am but to see i
was just talking to your last guest
about it to see behind the curtain would
be i think a little um
unsettling of course but you should do
it anyway you seem curious i am well
that's one of the reasons i love doing
the show i just i am curious what what
was the impetus for doing your show
you know what happened you mean the
podcast the podcast yeah i was always
doing business advice constantly and uh
hearing the same questions again and
again and again i realized there are
several themes that people want to know
like how to start the business how do i
get my confidence is this thing going to
work how do i get the funding
um i'm in a tough patch how do i get
through i have a problem with an
employee
should i have a partner there's only a
certain number of categories of advice
so i kept getting the same thing same
thing same thing i thought i guess a lot
of people really have these questions
and that's what i thought hey let me do
a podcast answer the same questions and
that's all it was at first just
answering one question after another
after another from letters from callers
from callers and then we got a lot of
callers a lot of emails a lot of texts
and most of them honestly came in that
way and then once i got 80 day barber
going everybody calls in i probably get
200 calls a day some of them are
ridiculous oh i want to hear some of
them are great you know some of the kind
of odd people what which ones stand out
well i think if i was going through i
was going through a bunch this morning
trying to think what's good for the next
couple of weeks yeah uh we got a call
from a lady uh she was sound very
reasonable and very sincere
and she said um how did she put it was
the way she said it that's always in oh
she said she said i really really need
to leave my husband i've been married
god awful number of years and she said i
really really need to leave him can you
tell me specifically what my steps are i
need to leave them on monday on monday
that's it that's the odd oddity like
monday
what's happening on monday or tuesday
yeah it had to be monday well bachelor
is on monday night maybe she wanted to
be free of him to washington maybe
people ask all kinds of things people
disclose things on a phone line that
always surprised me like i'm not having
sex with my husband last night we were
in bed i'm like i don't want to hear it
well but isn't that the good stuff i
mean don't you want to hear that you
seem to me to be very uh open to that
kind of stuff you
made some fun comments when you came in
to the you know i would say body maybe
oh i'm a bit body yeah yeah yeah
in this world it's a little dangerous
yes i know i know well yes uh why
i'm kidding i'm kidding why is it
dangerous or why my body no it is
dangerous i know um but is that so or do
you often find yourself editing
when you know when you're on the air
obviously you do you ever get paranoid
that you've said something no i'm not
often saying something whoops whoops
yeah and trusting that somebody's going
to edit it out right that's the nice
thing about
the podcast that's nice they protect
your ass yeah well on a podcast even on
shark tank i mean it's owned by disney
they watch me they should be x-rated uh
x-rated shark tank i would be the star
now
i keep the camera
isn't that always so satisfying when the
camera guys laugh you know you're
engaging yeah that doesn't mean the guys
who on the show like it very well of
course yeah when i went on dancing with
the stars and i was the number one loser
first one rejected oh i like that you
phrase it number one loser yeah
i was number three right number one at
something um all my bosses at shark tank
sat me down they all individually called
me and gave me a lecture online remember
nobody's got your back nobody's editing
out your lewd comments remember you got
to watch what you say yeah they were so
worried they were delighted when i got
eliminated
you know leah thompson was on the show
and she said uh she said that when she
got eliminated it was very difficult it
was a very pressure filled environment
that dancing with the stars it is it's a
pressure cooker that's what she said
hardest thing i've ever done really
so was it somewhat of a relief to to
no it was not a relief because the night
before we performed you know it was the
first competition they sent all of us a
note in our trailers in our in our uh or
our hotels wherever we were staying we
all got a lovely note saying pack your
pajamas this is the truth a toothbrush a
carry bag because if you're rejected
we're going to put you on a plane to new
york to go on good morning america or
was it the today show i think good
morning america good morning america
anyway um i read that note
tore it up put in the garbage yeah
everybody came with their little night
bags but not for me so i was stunned
when i said thank you very much oh you
were very confident there oh yes i flew
in new york in my gown because they
meant it they put you there there's a
metal staircase they rush you down the
metal staircase behind a closed door
that you've been passing all week in
practice but you've never noticed before
they get you on the plane you go in the
bowels of lax on to the runway home
people could go on the runway
jet blue
empty plane and then after you're in
your seat locked in and they have a
security guard with your big ass yeah
out of here i'm not making this up and
then the rest of the plane comes on
boards
get to new york same routine security
guard now i had a woman escorted me into
it it was terrible wait forgive me like
a prisoner what is the point of the
security guard they don't want you to
escape this is i didn't realize then
what it was but would i have escaped if
i could have after that heavy rejection
in my ball gown flying to new york
probably oh my god but you had no choice
because to the woman who's with me in
the armored car and i'm telling dark
windows
there's something really dehumanizing
about that
demoralizing demoralizing i would say
and i probably shouldn't be saying this
maybe they'll be upset but i don't think
so this is their routine but anyway on
the way to new york i say hey we're
passing by my apartment can i just stop
and and i want to get a suit to wear or
something i want to look like a business
lady get my ego back yeah they said no
we're on the strict direction not to
stop anyway
and we went to good morning america and
what do you think um i forget who
interviewed me i can't remember i guess
i know blocked it out no i guess i
blocked it out but anyway whoever was
interviewing first question i do
remember the question they said so what
is it
how did they put it they said so what is
it like to be a loser
oh it's great i love it it was so much
fun and at that point on my smiley face
you're probably that's i mean i would be
sort of
i don't know with pissed
embarrassed
nobody really likes a public
embarrassment
and i've had them my whole life and i
thought if they were going to pick up
someone that's good at it should be me
but there i was feeling like i was
experiencing it for the very first time
my ego crashed oh man that sucks and
also something that you were working
hard on like i i know that dancing so
hard yeah right but i was never in
better shape all those wrinkles i have
as an older woman in my legs that
wrinkly [ __ ] was all gone my legs tone
oh wow they went away two months later
yeah because i didn't keep it up well
what was the thing if you could tell
people like the dancing with the stars
routine what would you do i mean you um
i mean it was probably one of the best
experiences i'm telling you what was
shocking about it yeah so let me give it
two credits and credence i actually
learned how to dance even though they
didn't agree with me i know how to do
all those dances now that's cool um you
get a really handsome hunk of a guy
that's gonna dance with you five hours a
day so you smooth out the wrinkles you
get to get your hands on a hunk yeah so
far this sounds pretty good except for
the embarrassment part of it yeah and
you're in your free flight goal oh a
free flight you should jump just
anywhere nice yeah
it's it's a blast but it's a lot of hard
work yeah yeah it's what i've heard well
well we spent way too much time on that
didn't we no i don't think so i think
that's a very relatable story all of our
listeners who have been on dancing with
the stars themselves um this is no all
those people that's how i was saying
it's the idea of a public embarrassment
that everybody's watching you're a loser
but you know what what you really
realize is afterwards when i talked to
my friends or what did you think which
they thought it was amazing for trying
you're amazing amazing that's all their
read on it absolutely nobody cares you
lose they just admire you for getting
out and trying absolutely and it's the
way you lose it's the way the grace with
which you lose and the humor i think
yeah that's a good lesson laughing all
the way home oh it's the only way you
can do it i'm only kidding i cried oh
well you strike me as somebody who has
had a lot of confidence throughout their
lives is that true or am i just reading
answers not true of anyone oh you're
kidding me no no no well i'm just now
meeting you at this point in your life
you know what i think i think and i
think this goes for everyone i've met
who appear confident and seem successful
seem like they have their act together i
think uh they usually prepare better
than the next guy
they've taken more swings at the bat so
to speak than the next guy uh they try
harder they're always showing up and you
get you simply get better at it and so
people start falling for it you start
making things look easy but no i think
the most confidence seeming people are
usually uh
the people who are most insecure at the
start gate that's what i think that's
interesting but then what gave you the
um the will i guess to continue to
because you
seem like and if your tweets are to be
believed you uh fight for the yourself i
mean you you fight for your position at
the table uh you had another tweet that
i'm going to read because it's very
inspirational um every successful person
i know was willing to take a leap of
faith in themselves
i agree with myself
this was only a day ago you said that i
hope you still agree with yourself uh
but but what what it what was it about
your upbringing where where do you think
you forged that that oh i know where i
forged it right uh through uh duress and
i think most people forged strength
through duress you really if you think
about it you learn a lot of stuff but
you don't learn the real important stuff
unless you've blown it i think that it
stays with you you know you say i'm not
going to do that again or i learn this
from that you know even the worst things
that happened to you when you get past
them everything you look back you
realize i'm thank god you know thank god
that happened this other thing happened
because of it yeah but in the heat of it
or in the pain of it you don't see that
it's impossible it's too much to ask for
yourself so for me uh what i well what i
have is the wisdom of years looking back
that helps a lot to get to calm down
about stuff right
but even when i was younger
i realized where my strength came from
my strength came from uh just being a
lousy student at school and being
laughed at because it was so painful to
be oh poor herp or her not trying to do
a poor her whatever your everybody's got
their [ __ ] in childhood you know name
one person who doesn't that was mine and
so for me um
it was such a long uh a long walk
through the school system and a painful
one
that i became an over preparer i over
prepare for everything i work work
circles around the next guy because i
don't want to be embarrassed i don't
want to be a loser my whole life so once
again
yeah yeah but every time i went to a job
which i've had jobs since i was 11
people loved me it wasn't based on math
skills or reading out loud you know bad
you know isn't that funny you think
about some of that stuff that you
struggled with that i i did as well matt
you did math skills are terrible i i
don't remember i don't remember what it
even what it was i don't remember the
best it went wrong or
what what i was supposed to know that i
didn't know that it was a source of
shame but you remember how you felt
about it absolutely that's the important
thing to remember yeah you know not the
equation you missed but that you're a
loser and then what it does is it makes
you feel like i got to be good at
something yeah and it gives you that
power to work extra hard well it's
similar i mean like you you do that
quote about relationships i think
you know the wisdom of age of time i
think perhaps your
last relationship was so successful
because and i think this about a lot of
quote-unquote unsuccessful relationships
i've been in you know where you lament
the time that you spent on them and and
then in retrospect you think well i i i
know now what i'm not to do or or what
sometimes sometimes yeah no ideally yeah
um i married my first husband twice come
on oh wow yeah yeah really not literally
my first husband i married another guy
that looks so different and actually so
different i said oh this guy here is
opposite to my first husband that didn't
work out yeah only to find out a few
years later they were the same guy oh
interesting because it was once you get
to really know
yeah you tend to i think especially in
deep relationships you tend to repeat
patterns a little bit yeah but then but
then that is uh that's the success there
is a success in that even in having done
it twice yes that the third time seems
like it was a charm well you know what
happened well actually it's been two
times three boyfriends two husbands but
um
the the charm of
the third time as you put it which is my
second husband bill who i've married so
many years
is i realize going in it's probably not
anybody better out there when things get
tough i used to look around i swear to
god in the early years with bill and
when i go oh god is this worth the work
is this worth the work
i would look around and all the husbands
my friends are married to them say would
i rather have him right oh god no that's
right that could stick you sticky with
you your original guy yeah that's
weirdly romantic yeah it's hard to put
on a hallmark card but uh well it could
be worse yeah it could be um happy
anniversary dear but marriage is work
talk to anybody that has a successful
marriage they'll tell you they work
really hard yeah well you had mentioned
i think maybe before we started rolling
um that there are eight different you
said they were like categorized people
into eight seven or eight different
groups yeah yeah you're not going to ask
me for the groups
types of people yeah
you describe me as scrappy which i agree
you are scratching yeah yeah and that
came up because when we walked into your
shop here
you felt like you had met my colleague
before and i commented no she's just a
type you've met that's what happens it's
only eight or nine different types in
life so here's the scrappy type okay you
know you're the type that the girls look
at
raise the brown go oh he's hot oh wow
and he's got he's a lot of fun
and then when they get into the
relationship they realize you're very
complicated uh wow wow interesting am i
right that's the scrappy type yeah oh
scrappy wasn't as good as i thought it
was really no no it's very very good
because you attract people you should be
flattered but you track people but
you're complicated you know scrappy guys
are complicated that's what makes them
intriguing and interesting because you
kind of get hooked in on them because
they're ooh aren't they interesting oh
i'm i'm still kind of flattered i don't
know if i'm that complicated maybe i'm
not flattered or that flattered yeah or
that scrappy uh so how what would you be
what type are you
uh i'm too much a straight shooter okay
i'm the type that just a lot of people
love me right away they fall in love
with me god she really tells it like it
is very accessible i'm very accessible
yeah you come on in i put my carpet out
stay at my house come over tonight have
a bed no problem i'm very easy going oh
and then it goes down the road a bit
goes down the road
like how long are you going to be
staying now
and then you realize if i decide i don't
like you you'll never see me again
i slam that door as quickly as i open it
so that's the downside to the openness
you see oh no and is that to protect
yourself probably of course because when
you have an open door to every kind of
tom dick and harry in the world and
you're open and you could see
their perspective and walk in their
shoes and have great empathy for people
all that comes with openness yeah uh
people take advantage so that when you
finally you're the latest person to
realize that guy's a creep yeah so when
you slam the door you slam it harder
than anybody else's legs still in it so
that hurts
by the way where's your brother i
thought you did this with your brother
christian i do barbara who has nine
siblings and he is better looking uh i
do he does the we do the intro where we
talk about the guest and our that's all
he does and then we do the outro and so
we kind of uh unpack the conversation a
little bit and he yeah so you need to
analyze it after the fact yes what about
yourself you were the second of ten yeah
second exam good position to be in
middle child
yeah well how
what were the advantages of that and
disadvantages well you know i had uh one
older sister denise and she was
constantly in trouble she was around
arouser uh had a hard time with
authority constantly thrown out of
school constantly in trouble denise and
then below me i had my oldest brother
who's a year younger the oldest boy in
the family and he was constantly
punished around aroused they were the
troublemakers in the family so i had my
flanks covered all i had to do is kind
of just walk through the middle and i
was fine were you a bit of a peacemaker
were you trying to i'm not really i was
just uh you know i would hate to say a
good politician but i could smell
trouble with my dad with my mom yeah
when there was going to be trouble and i
would know how to hide oh interesting
people a low profile you know what i
mean i was the lovely child nice and
quiet
how does that benefit you now would you
say i mean do you see versions of that
behavior yes i kind of think myself in
any relationship as a middleman i guess
that's why i became a real estate broker
maybe i was always the middle person
making the deal right but i think i'm a
good middle person too well maybe a
peacemaker would be good but i'm good at
building bridges between negotiating
yeah yeah yeah
making something happen because i know
how to get through a rough patch and the
rough patch is often between two people
oh you find that happens quite often on
shark tank on the show itself uh no on
the shark tank show uh we don't want to
have peacemakers our job there is to be
sharks so i i'm less my real personality
i think if i was peacemaking between
sharks uh probably i wouldn't be on the
show for like two years
she's not tough enough oh that's right
and and with a family that size i
imagine there's often
discord there's often
you know there's got to be drama
happening i i only have three in my
family well my mom who attend always
said when she had three she was out of
control it made no difference and she
really believed that okay but i can tell
you i remember having three which is
denise barbara
eddie that was it yeah it seemed like a
little family and it seemed calm once we
had 10 there was nothing calm we're a
year and a half apart it just seemed
like
it was like chaos all the time oh my god
but uh i really believe in hindsight my
mother was made for having 10 kids so
was my dad they wanted 12. they never
quite made it because they wanted 12.
yeah nice even dozen oh my god they were
devout catholics they used the pope's
rhythm method so that's why we're all a
year and a half apart oh
accurately they shot so to speak you
know oh my god wait what is the rhythm
method i thought the rhythm method was
it gives the wife a break for a year
after she gives birth
oh my god i'm sorry not a year six six
months yeah i was like my math is not
that bad you time yourself so the wife
does not get pregnant for six months
they did that religiously yes
oh my god these kids yeah oh the diddy
the ditty part is the resting part yeah
you know what's great about a big family
on a serious note uh you have the chaos
um you certainly don't have enough to go
around that makes it tight but it makes
you want more it makes it leaves you
wanting yeah this thing's scrappier
probably yeah yeah yeah and more
importantly you learn how to get along
with people probably every single person
in my family is great in people's skills
get along with anybody
we're all leaders there's not a single
person in my family who doesn't lead
whatever they do for a living that's odd
and 8 out of 10 of us are entrepreneurs
so we're all independent-minded even
though you think we'd be codependent in
such close quarters but you you cut
you're kind of forced when you're in a
crowd to make your own way even in the
streets of new york you know you have
your own bubble you kind of like etch
out for yourself sure it's the same way
in a family you have to etch out your
own little space in your dominant
territory and play a certain role so it
kind of prepares you for life very
easily you were all working early by 10
or 11 we all had jobs
in them we're all making money was money
important to you when you were a kid
well it was i'll tell you why because if
you wanted something new you had to make
your own money you know everything was
hand-me-downs and a large family
and in uh in my family you had to make
money because they had to contribute to
the household we had two bedrooms we had
10 kids
parents in the living room and that
sounds like oh my god that's terrible it
wasn't it honest to god it was a happy
family because you didn't know any
different it was like a tribe right yeah
um but uh what why we wanted to make
money is because we gave half our money
back to the family whatever we made you
know babysitting or earlier on than
waitressing whatever you did to scrap
and half the money went in your pocket
the freedom of having your own cash at
ten or eleven oh i remember that it was
the ten bucks i mean you felt like i'm
the man on campus oh i used to sell all
these odd things i would go and catch
tadpoles and i would sell them
individually as pets no one really
bought them but i was so into having
money and i'd mow lawns all the time i
was really into this but it gives you
confidence
early confidence yeah and freedom like
yeah like you said there's something
exciting about being able to even if it
was like football cards just being able
to buy going into a store where adults
went yeah and getting your own um well
it's that power saying i'll take that
yeah
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
was religion important to you when you
were growing up and you said catholic uh
um can i tell you i'm embarrassed to say
i'm not the least religious the minute i
turned 21 was out of the house i never
saw a church again but you have to
realize in my family when we all went to
church every morning my mother was
devour every morning every morning
before school we went to early mass
seven o'clock all marched in like little
penguins behind my mother my dad didn't
go he was already at work but um that
was our way of life so when i got out of
that house man the last thing i want to
ever do is go to a catholic church or
any church it's kind of a shame in a way
because i have two kids of my own who
have no religion i went the other way
where are they thank god but that's
about it yeah are they curious now about
have they not really well my son tommy
is uh 25 no he's not religious so my
daughter is 13 and she's not either okay
one day they'll probably become
religious zealots because i haven't
given them religion yes exactly
winds up right they'll start cults in
the hills of california um i mean
fingers crossed uh that's interesting
and i wouldn't be embarrassed by that in
fact it's a common thing i've heard it
on this show many times people who grow
up with a very
uh
over over
yeah yeah and then you
uh it took me a while because we were
catholic
yeah i read that my parents are still
very devout and uh oh we were altar boys
oh yeah it was a big part of our lives
wow um i hope it was an uneventful altar
boy career it was it wasn't as uh
scandalous as as it was
fortunately there weren't those awful
stories uh in fact i had a very
important role model in my life with my
god my godfather
he was uh a missionary a catholic
missionary for divine word missionaries
in new guinea oh wow and he was a bit
like being a saint
he was the same he was saint lee the
things he did and it wasn't about
spreading a particular ideology he
helped poor people i mean he brought
wells and clean drinking water to these
people and and um a genuine good man a
good man and and died early of of bone
cancer and
bone marrow cancer and continued his
work up until even when it was painful
and he was should have been treated but
he was a massive sturdy guy uh
father joe he was a great man and and so
i was fortunate i was you know you hear
these awful stories obviously about the
the church but but my one of a
role model for me was uh a catholic
priest so i kind of had the opposite
experience he knew no other way but to
keep giving when he was sick right yeah
to the point where i mean he probably
could have prolonged his life had he not
he was just a real like you said saintly
well we had in our family my mother's
brother was a christian brother
and he was charming good-looking dapper
dan he had all the nice friends he
brought over the other christian
brothers we adored him
and uh he was
i'm sure with your uncle as well he was
the hero of the family to have in a
catholic family someone who goes with
the cloth of god
is such an honor it's like gave you
bragging rights well it's one of the
reasons my dad was in the seminary for
seven years be trump wanted to be a
priest seven years lucky for you he
wasn't i know fortunately his natural
urges overpowered his desire to die yeah
i know that we wouldn't be here you you
would have a free afternoon
it doesn't work out for you
yeah i bet um did you struggle with
every subject in school was it just
particularly matters i just couldn't
read and do numbers which is basically
most of what you have in
your early years right that's what it's
about yeah um and and at what point did
you gain confidence at what point did
you start succeeding oh you know what i
never did succeed in school but i think
the more important uh thing was when did
i learn to read yeah okay so by seventh
grade i wasn't reading but when
i was uh 14 my mother gave me the book
wuthering heights
charlotte bronte emily bronte yeah and i
got into it she read me the first few
pages i got into it and by the end of
the summer i finished the book and i
realized i knew how to read i know that
sounds like hogwash but that's really
how it happened how cool and then she
gave me gone with the wind which was so
sexy and then she gave me the one with
heathrow the dark guy that was uh
heathcliff he's cliff yeah was that one
well that's weathering heights oh that's
withering heights oh then she gave me a
third one with a with maybe i'm wrong i
might be wrong no no that's right thank
you
it might be heathcliff
great work of liberty no the lover
heathcliff and he marries that girl who
didn't want any part of him he's rich he
lives by himself
yeah the first one then uh it was gone
with the win and then she gave me now i
forget which one another lover boy book
and yeah i realized i was reading i mean
slow but oh cool
and is reading still important to you is
that still problem i don't read much
because it takes me so long to read
something yeah yeah no so but
but i listened to a lot of books because
that's easy for me we didn't have that
when i was a kid that's not a boom to
children who can't read that's true i
never thought about that what a great
for this generation yeah what were you
interested in as a kid was it about
wanting to be better in school was it
about yeah i gave up early yeah by
second grade i'd given up forget it i
was daydreaming if you could have only
tapped into my head and gotten it on a
piece of paper the stories that were
going on in my head i would have been a
great anything yeah but it couldn't come
out you know it couldn't come out it was
trapped but you know what i got good at
by the time i was in sixth or seventh
grade because i just kind of got fed up
with uh you know looking like i was a
dumb kid i started getting good with my
mouth and i've always been able to talk
well oh and that's a huge part of that
humorous yeah i could be fast on my feet
with a comeback yeah i could persuade
kids to follow me i got i had the
biggest club on my block you know they
all want to be in my club i was the most
fun what was the club called it was
calling from you gosh i don't even want
to tell you it was great
well now i want to know more it was
called a showing high knees club
i would have been in that club
i i would have excelled in that club you
would have been welcome yeah you could
have been the vice president wait
what uh i mean i hate that i think you
know what the nature of the club yeah i
can imagine
is it as self-explanatory yes it is but
i should have had the smarts to name it
something else i could have
i could have actually yes
what's the name of your club and i could
have said it's always square four block
club but you sound good oh you could
have said anything yeah the shc yeah
yeah yeah and you were the president and
i was the president but it was popular i
bet who doesn't like a hiney and
everyone has a hiney it's perfect and i
found that every kids were egalitarian
every kid was willing to show it if you
told them to do it of course well
certainly if they were in the club if
that was the rules and that was my
leadership ability right then and
they're amazing
that's really funny and if you uh until
my mother showed up oh i bet you the the
clubhouse was charlie's boat there was
this old sweet guy who's building a boat
in a garage behind a house in our town
he was an adult
an adult an older man lovely lovely man
he let us play in no he wasn't part of
the club oh okay he said go play in the
boat he's sanctioned in the club oh
that's a little weird well he didn't
even
he didn't know what we were doing okay
and when he came up to work on the boats
he worked on a few hours every day he
was building a boat and this is a true
story he knocked down the garage
eventually and sailed away on the hudson
river you'd swear that was bad that's so
cool cool guy and then he came back
about two years late and gave all the
kids in my family my mother my father
wasn't there he was working he gave us a
ride on the hudson river on his boat
that was my showing highness club
clubhouse
which kind of made it feel a little
a little taboo but what i wanted to say
is when charlie came up which was
usually around 4 4 15 in the afternoon
after we've been playing the club he
always put the hineys away yeah we knew
he was coming up he'd say what are you
kids doing in there or something like
that and our we would all chimey and i
had everyone trained we'd all join back
making spaghetti we'd bang pots
these kids sure love spaghetti
that's really funny that went on for a
couple of summers yeah that's really
funny after you graduated from college
you taught speaking of i don't know how
to make this transition after you
graduated from college you taught for a
year yes i did that's in for someone who
struggled so in in school
that's really no i had a lot of lucky
breaks here's what happened i graduated
from liona high school
and i was i know for a fact i was the
second lowest ranked uh person in the
entire high school graduating class
because in those days they would they
would have you come to the
not the cafeteria the gymnasium they'd
line up all the seniors in the gymnasium
you sit in alphabetical order
and then what they would do they would
call out your name but they would call
out your name and who did worse on the
s.a.t or i think it was called something
different then but like college entrance
exams they would call out your name on
who did worse and there were two people
named before me
and when they called out my name i sat
down in my chair feeling embarrassed but
when i opened it up they had made a
mistake
i was in the top 10th percentile of the
whole graduation class so i went from
barely passing a course my whole life to
the top 10
and so i announced it to everything i
mean look look look i had everybody
around me look look i was in shock and
then someone behind me uh this one
really good looking smart kid that i
knew he said no you read it wrong you're
the bottom ten
it was so embarrassing but here's what
went well so that was embarrassing by
then i couldn't get embarrassed it was
kind of funny after a few minutes and
like you said like you know you're it's
controversy it's something to overcome
it's something to work through yeah but
you know every and not every girl in
edgewater where i grew up at that time
was a factory new jersey new jersey yeah
not every girl was getting pregnant in
high school but a lot were yeah but
everybody was getting married right
after the graduation sure so everyone
had a boyfriend it seemed except for me
i'm sure there were other girls that
didn't have boyfriends but i couldn't
see them so i didn't have a boyfriend i
wasn't getting married i'm like god what
do i do the showing hiney's club had no
more members
i had to just fail on my 13th birthday
okay because i was so much taller than
everybody else
your honey was more developed i was
worried about going to jail yeah i get
it i didn't know where that mark was
when she's announced
charlie was like i know you're not
making spaghetti at this point yeah i
think i think i disbanded the club
before he sailed away and i had the good
judgment to do that yeah but here's what
happened there was a nunnery in spark
hill new york that made nuns you know it
was i forget what it was called not a
nunnery but yeah it wasn't a nun factory
and they couldn't get enough nuns the
things were changing so they let in
confidence
so they let in lay students and a girl
up the street was going there she had
just been admitted she said come on up i
think they'll even get into the school i
went up they interviewed me they didn't
even ask for my my nothing my marks
anything they accepted me on the spot
the nun that's what they checked your
puzzle and they're like you're in oh yes
please we'd love to have you join us
basically the requirement was you were
catholic so there i went and i got to
know college it seemed like a miracle
wow it was it was really that was a
lucky break if they didn't open it that
day if i didn't know mary lodato who
introduced me to hey i wouldn't have
gotten another benefit of the catholic
system you got it um wow so that that
was a cut that was a four-year four-year
college yeah and i became a teacher
after that that's what you were asking
yeah what did you teach
i taught english and theology because i
was a theology and philosophy major and
that was at st joseph's high school
in uh west new york i guess it was but
only for a year st joseph's high school
yeah a lot of basketball players come
from there right is that that basketball
that's me no okay i don't know i was
struggling to get my curriculum together
i didn't know who was playing what oh
wow my dad taught uh philosophy for many
years
yes he is he was a philosophy yes uh
what was your so you taught in the high
school so it was kind of general
philosophy theology
medieval philosophies just whatever book
they gave me yeah basically read from
the book as best i could and had the
guys it was a boy's high school guys
discuss stuff good for you it wasn't for
me yeah yeah
so afterwards what what was what did you
want to do what was your ambition well i
didn't have an ambition honestly um i
was out of school at 21 i already had
had 20 jobs i loved every job i did not
like the teaching job and i did not like
working as a nurse's aide which i also
had for a while
other than that i loved every job
because i was on my feet talking and you
didn't have to really know anything you
know yeah you could you could use your
mouth to kind of get you yeah kind of
get you get yourself through so um so
anyway my favorite jobs are always
waitressing i love waiting it's like
sales on your feet i kind of like that
too if the day flies by you get
compensated based on how good you are
it's a fair business yeah and you make
your own hours so for me i loved it but
then
i got my other very good lucky break
when ramon simone walked into the diner
one night ramon simone what a name from
the basque country and one look at him i
knew i'd lose my virginity within the
month
you just know about that when you're a
girl really but anyway you reopened the
showing your highness club well that was
just showing the stuff you're not using
it right now
it's a whole different club much better
use this stuff is what i found ramon
simone what a name well it was made up
his real name was ray simon but he
decked himself out
yeah ray simon's not a bad name oh but
it's not as cool as ramon samantha
that's true
sounds like raven simone though now to
me that's so ramon so he gave me the
thousand dollars to start a real estate
company when i was 23 and if not for
that wow i don't know what i'd be doing
i'm sure i would have done well working
right because i was a good worker but
who knows a thousand dollars how do you
start a real estate company
you know real estate uh companies
brokerage firms i should say not if
you're gonna build a building that's
different but to start a brokerage firm
if you think about it i don't want to
make the business sound too simple but
it's a relatively simple business
you need a telephone
okay or who doesn't have a telephone
yeah you need some kind of an
advertisement somewhere to draw on a
customer in those days was the new york
times spot ads classified columns so you
need a three-line ad
and you need an apartment to rent
and so i was working as a receptionist
for some older men in town who owned a
lot of properties they gave me my first
listing i asked them hey could you give
me my first listing they were nice i
worked for them they liked me they said
okay
and i put a three line ad in the paper
and i had a telephone i even paid an
extra dollar a month because you could
get a princess foam pink
i had a fancy one
you're wearing a pink shirt i should
point out no i didn't i don't know no no
i'm telling you listeners you're not
you're currently wearing it oh yes i am
okay you're they're very very pink right
now um
and that and in your business think
about that that's all you really needed
being done you didn't have an mls then
the mls was the local newspaper and
anyone could buy an ad there so once you
sold your first apartment it was it off
to the races was it like okay now this
is going to work if it gets worse well
you know what i wasn't in the sale
business because i couldn't afford it uh
in sales you have to wait for a closing
and you're waiting three months for a
commission and you're usually working
with someone two to three months six
months before you get your hands on
money no that wasn't my kind of business
my kind of business was you rent the
apartment that day and when you hand in
the first month's rents and the first
one security to the landlord's office he
handed you a whole month's commission
back that was my kind of business yeah
immediately instant cash yeah and most
people in real estate especially in city
environments start out rentals for that
reason it's called cash flow very
important need yeah but when i got my
first check for 340 dollars for the one
bedroom i rented for joe jafuni
another brother andrew yeah oh my god
you remember these names do you ever
normally have a good memory or is it
just because it was such an important a
significant event i have a less good
memory as i get older but i certainly
remember all the important people my
life always yes yes yes i'll remember
you oh thanks min jo jafuni when i got
that check i went i spent the money on
the best thing i could so i had a
thousand i had already spent about maybe
120 on ads and taxi fares and getting
the phone done and everything so i'm
down like you know say i have a little
less than 900 left then i get 340. i
think do the math on that i went from
900 to like 12 50. yeah first week in
business and i thought holy god so i
went out and bought myself a brand new
coat for 320 dollars a coat a fancy coat
oh that's cool did you like clothes is
that something that's funny i had no
clothes i always had hand-me-downs
and i wanted to be you wanted to project
uh
yeah i wanted to be the fancy real
estate girl yeah and the coat i had on
my p code didn't look so fancy but once
i put that
fancy ass herringbone brown and white
thing on boy i was fancy that's
interesting yeah and people treat you
differently maybe they treated me so
differently you know it was it was
remarkable people kind of like turn
their eye now i realized was the the the
coat was so gaudy yeah so terrible
looking i had no taste
uh but uh still i was noticed yeah well
i bet well right it just has to happen
you know that's what happened when i
bought my first fancy clown wig
no you didn't no no i didn't uh
so so you are now in business with your
at the time boyfriend ramon simone
51 of the company that's what he took oh
he was a controlling partner how do you
do that with someone you're in a
relationship with is that different um
you know it really worked out you know i
i moved in with him about a year later
and then his three girls moved in with
us i became kind of like their mom
and uh
he had a building business so he did
that on the side i ran the brokerage
office we are separate separate you know
companies really
uh and that worked out great so you did
that for a while we did that for seven
years and then one night he came home
when i'm um making pasta for the girls
in the sink i'd sing like a frozen frame
in time you know
and he said i have something serious to
discuss i'm going to marry tina
tina was my secretary i'm like you know
that [ __ ]
you know like suddenly i hate it yeah
isn't that funny so cliche too so cliche
it happens all the time but anyway that
was the end of that wow and that's when
i started corcoran group so you had
found success then in the real estate
world you're doing well are you happy
then is does that bring happiness
uh what brings happiness uh the only
thing that brings happiness is giving
that's in my opinion what brings
happiness you've given a lot in life i'm
sure your uncle was probably the
happiest member of your family that was
my godfather uh yeah oh your godfather
not also uncle my uncles are fairly
happy i have an uncle no no i mean the
the priest guy yeah that's my godfather
but he's not related that's not just
she's the mother's brother or something
right that's true he was my dad's
colleague someone who my dad really
respected oh i'm more of a careful
choice yeah yeah uh he seemed happy you
know he did even when he was dying he
seemed
uh giving gives satisfaction i'm not
trying to sound like a pollyanna but
yeah to your question was i happy
building the company of course i was
because i was hiring people that loved
me i love them back
i got to choose who came in who who
stayed who went out
um i had the freedom to make my world
unlike uh anything that was imposed on
me in my whole life
i got to make my own world freedom
many people came to know you came to
know your face when you were on shark
tank uh
was that what how was that an easy
decision i would imagine it might it
might come with a little bit of um
hesitation to be on shark tank yeah i
was desperate to be on oh okay well then
never mind yeah yeah i was wrong all
right no hesitation didn't mean to
counter you no no only because like you
know if you're you have this level of
respect in the real estate world in the
business world to then be on a show i
would imagine on a tv show i would
imagine that might make you look bad not
bad just like oh you're now
an entertainer or you're now
not disrespected oh and it
you know what i think i think if you do
any kind of entertainment work and you
known
for it
and you would answer that better than i
uh i'll ask you the same question maybe
um i don't i think you get more respect
whether it's earned or not it's called
some kind of a celebrity card
and people adore you regardless of if
you're going home at night beating your
wife they adore you because they know
you or they feel they know you right
they feel like they have an inside track
so i found
that when i was a businesswoman uh
raising the corker group like all my
kids that i was raising that's how i
felt they were my family i felt like i
earned every inch of respect by my
actions yeah not my words my actions
yeah and that's what got people to
follow me but when i went on shark tank
the minute it got some notoriety which
took about three years
um i found that everybody respected me
immediately regardless of that and i'm
not sure that was earned at all oh god i
can't like a free ride you get of course
to get loved in a way that doesn't make
any sense exactly exactly and it's not
connected to anything as you say earned
um that's why it's always such a
struggle about self-worth yes
how did that
what were your struggles how did that
change your life
the best thing oh the celebrity thing
yeah oh not really much i mean you know
what what it does to my life is it gives
me great notoriety no i was very well
known in new york city because i
promoted myself so aggressively to kill
the firm
so i would walk down the street in new
york city and people say oh you're the
real estate lady oh you're the real
estate you're on billboards and stuff
you i paid for them of course yeah
yeah yeah but at discount rates i always
took the scrapper rate you don't have
somebody can i have it for a month and
then they wouldn't have somebody for the
next month oh can i get a cheaper rate
oh really yeah i always hustle good good
deals yeah it's funny we were talking
about um
jingles before because you you had come
violated come up with did she come up
with a jingle for your podcast no
actually uh a guy i met on a on a flight
from l.a came up with the jingle really
and it's funny i'm sitting on a plane
from l.a in a coach seat because i
refuse to pay the price
and i'm sitting next to a handsome young
guy and he has a note paper and he's
writing very few things on it and i'm
thinking ah he's in the creative field i
bet he's in production i bet he's a
writer so by the time the flight goes
over and i'm sitting thinking i need a
jingle for my podcast how do i get a
jingle who do i know that might know
jingle writers how do you get a shingle
writer yeah what do you tell them i'm
thinking like this and then i see him
right and i go
i bet you're a writer or at least
writing for something creative for me
and he said he said yes i am he said he
said i'm a movie maker i said oh
terrific you know anyone who might write
jingles he says i write jingles
what was his name damian uh damien yeah
your kid chazelle
uh i don't know
it was i don't know
yeah good nice guy
does documentary movies oh maybe not
damien oh sorry but that was his first
day oh well anyway next thing i knew it
he was making me a jingle and said i
won't charge you i'd love to make you
jingle weird just pay the singers i said
no problem i got myself a jingle
lyrics to a jingle that's a little kind
of imitation oh
that's a funny thing to do jingle jingle
life could be a dream
[Music]
people must pitch you things all the
time inventions yeah but it's adorable
yeah listen i came up with my big lie in
season two
because every cab i got into i said well
maybe season no i think it came up in
season two but anyway people were
starting to pitch me in restaurants on
streets i gave a presentation somewhere
people are waiting in line to give me
their pitch hand me their business idea
whatever it was overwhelming i realized
i was going to give up my whole life if
i listened to pitches so i came up with
the big lie and here it goes it goes
like this and i'll tell it to you if you
if you hit me in on the street i told
the cabbie coming here today in the
mirror he was pitching me an idea oh
really he says i'm on the contract with
abc i'm not allowed to listen to any
pitches i hope you understand but go on
shark tank submit your pitch it's right
online oh that's good that's good oh oh
oh oh oh well
because i haven't experienced this
deluge of of pitches i'm curious what
was his pit do you remember do you
remember any of it i don't hear a
picture oh you don't hear that no no no
no
i did get caught with a pitch about
three weeks ago at uh laguardia airport
in the ladies room because the lady's
legs
in the next stall was pitching me an
idea get out of here and i was in such
shock that she was actually pitching
again you know around the little you got
speaking of hustling you gotta respect
that well whatever she was saying didn't
make a lot of sense in fact i'm not sure
if she was all there but she's like
you've heard of two plies this is like
three plies i couldn't get my lie out
fast enough i couldn't shout under this
yeah hey here comes my life oh my god
surprise yeah pitching you in a stall
wow hey you gotta you gotta hand it to
people who hustle uh yeah
okay barbara well i have a few pitches
i'd like to run by you no i'm not no no
i'm kidding i'm out uh
but but then you think like well what if
there's an idea that that you poo poo or
you or you dismissed that's like gonna
be the next big thing well guess what i
did i tested that theory after two years
in shark tank i got so much mail so much
product mailed to my office hundreds and
hundreds of things i thought oh they
sent you prototypes oh definitely oh wow
there could be a great idea yeah i
thought there must be so i had about
four people at the office and i said
everybody divide it up four piles go
through and pick out the best ones oh
that's the cool assignment had maybe
seven 800 pitches a little less than a
thousand wow everybody went through them
looked at the product and the pile was
paper thin it was about six things and
it had taken us
collectively like four days to do it wow
and i thought to myself even if there
was a winner here it ain't worth it you
know the curiosity can kill the cat and
that curiosity was like look at this
stuff there must be gold under this pile
yeah there was so little gold it wasn't
worth digging through the pipe oh isn't
that funny you know what shark tank
probably listens to 50 pitches to have
one on the show yeah maybe it's 200 now
why did i think i might be more
proficient than that right that's true
it's like panning for a little bit
yeah right i'm like the amateur versus
let the pro get the gold although that
is a trip i really want to do a friend
of mine did that in alaska he was he was
pitching me that truck really where you
can go and pan for gold oh yeah yeah
yeah you wouldn't fall for that would
you no i'm smart i mean you don't get
enough to retire from but like you get
little tiny specks of it and just have
that experience that will tell you give
me a home address no actually there's a
pond in central park this little stream
i'll throw some gold in there so you can
save your money no barbara it's not the
actual getting of the gold it's the
doing it it's delicious
central park's a little different than
the wilds of alaska it's okay i mean it
wouldn't appeal to me but have fun um
do you ever really like an idea this
i've always wondered this do you ever
really like an idea on shark tank but
you kind of can't stand the person yes
all the time oh yeah i never invest you
know why i did a few things like that
the first couple of seasons yeah what
happens in shark tank is if you love the
person and you invest and the idea
doesn't make much sense you always make
money that's the truth because the
people that you're investing in our
winners they're going to find a way
they're going to find a way to reinvent
re-hustle get there to the finish line
yeah i always make money if i invest in
what i think that's a real clever
solution of the problem
if the person what it's kind of a turd
well if a person's a turd i'd never
invest but sometimes i've been tempted
with a mediocre person with a phenomenal
idea but still i lose my money
so now i've learned the secret to
investing in shark tank is to invest in
the individual and to almost um
not pay that much attention on what the
business is that's interesting
do the other shark tank members
believe that yeah oh no everybody's got
the right method you know what works for
them might not be what works for me but
that's what makes money and what makes
me lose money for sure oh that's
interesting if you if you had to start a
business with one of the sharks who
which one would it be oh of course mark
cuban wouldn't i mean he's got billions
we've got millions is a big difference
you know oh right he's got billions so
if you had something good he could just
put a billionaire in there oh my god
it's very different than having millions
and thinking i don't know how i feel
about this hundred thousand dollars yeah
exactly it means a little bit more also
he's a straight shooter he works fast
he's got a good team bang bang bang
everything gets done he likes doing
cameos on shows do you do you like he
does doesn't he yes to the point where
they're no longer really cameos they're
at that point you know like little parts
i don't know how you separate them uh on
entourage
yeah he actually oh the one on entourage
was adorable yeah that was a lot of
years ago it was yeah it was a good show
i love that i only referenced things
from at least a decade ago yeah um
i find listeners really respond to that
um but he has an agent just for that he
died he does like why would you want
that mark he says i love doing them what
do you do to relax you seem like you
seem strike me as somebody who seems
very relaxed and casual and yet you're
working all the time how how do you
maintain that
level of relaxation well i'm not casual
at all i'm working all the time i have a
very hard time relaxing i always have
interesting yeah as a kid i couldn't
relax as an adult i can't relax really
um but how i relax is by having fun for
me my idea of heaven on earth is
working on a project renovating a new
house i love that
it's exhausting the detail but it's a
project or planning a party you're a
real
party yeah yeah yeah get a bunch of
friends involved in planning the party
with me or get on the project or go on
vacation what can we do i guess that's
relaxing but i'm always the producer oh
and i just love the details because
always in my mind what it is going to be
is so much better than what it winds up
being right right it's like oh it's a
little bit short and like oh but the
next one i know i'll learn from that
yeah yeah does your husband like that is
he or she oh my husband you've got to
meet my husband bill oh my god he's so
opposite to me bill you want to go out
for dinner no
oh really hey bill you wanna nope he
sounds great oh he's great he's
obviously yeah he's a ball oh yeah he
sounds fun what what so he doesn't like
going out he just he's a homebody you
know what my husband builds an odd
character he is my opposite in every way
you make it a list of all my traits you
make a list of his yeah you'll see the
exactly opposite i say black he says
white how we got together i don't know
but what's great about him is solid as a
rock he's always there never moving
always there boom like a real rock and
i'm running around like a rabbit without
a head all the time well that's probably
how it works you hear that all the time
yeah yeah that's really nice everybody
calls him lucky bill
why because if he's because he's because
he's he's so well taken care of
but then people who really know him and
see our relationship together call him
poor bill so he's a lucky bill of poor
bill he's one of the others
what is it what does bill do again he's
been retired for i would say 25 years
which is amazing
lucky bill well lucky bill in that way
he married me and two years later he
retired he's like wait i didn't see that
coming but before that he owned a
business of brokerage business that's
why i met him in new jersey
he was a fbi agent he was a football
player at annapolis no way
yeah he had like a badge and a success
and everything then he marries me two
years later he says okay i'm gonna stay
home now what oh that's cool but they've
been home ever since well that probably
works for you too that's probably why
it's been 30 plus years it's easy to
plan around a guy that doesn't go
anywhere yeah yeah but once in a while
ago somewhere would be a lot of fun you
know you have two kids now so
tommy is the older one yeah and is he
he's in real estate he's in real estate
surprisingly oh that's cool i stole my
business when he was five because i had
a baby at 46 my first child so i was
very what yeah very old yeah
oh
but anyway i stole the business when he
was five thinking you know i'm not going
to make him one of these kids that
inherits a business and he can't have
his own world let me let the kid be
himself so he grows up and what do you
think he does oh he's not he goes in the
real estate business right yeah but
that's smart of you as a as a successful
person didn't work not so well well no
no i mean he's doing real estate but i'm
sure he also
development piece yeah yeah but i'm sure
he also cultivated like you know good
personality and a strong sense oh he's
got a lot of charm he's a hustler that's
cool yeah 46. amazing amazing it is i
mean that's like a physiological and i
adopted my second at 56. wow i was gonna
have another baby it just couldn't be
done well jenna jackson how old was she
she was 50 i think i think she was 50
yeah yeah uh but this wow
adopted at 56 good for you um
it's like what my godfather would do uh
and and has she followed in your
footsteps well she's only 13. oh okay
well so don't give her about two years
don't do the math on that okay okay
uh this these are the hard-hitting
questions that i apologize in advance
for asking what is your most commonly
used emoji
i would say the double heart oh that's
not you mean the one with the big one
and the little one at the same time
medium-sized one a little baby yeah you
know why it always feels like you have
an abundance of kisses or love or
whatever you convey more than the big
one yeah that's true this was sincere
yeah that's true that's funny if you
could be a professional athlete uh what
sport would you play oh i'm a great
skier i should have been a ski racer i
would have been the best i have no doubt
in my mind i have never gone down the
mountain any mountain where i didn't see
a hot ass guy skier where i didn't
compete with him and beat him
why does he have to be hot because when
you see a guy that's got
nice buns yeah hiney
yeah i didn't say that a hella good
behind him you see him he's a great
skier he looks beautiful he has no fear
he's hopping like crazy he's going at
top speed yeah it's a beautiful sight
and then i realized well if he thinks
he's better than me i'll show him which
is ridiculous because he's not skiing to
show me up of course it's funny to be
competitive with somebody you're
physically attracted to just because
you're attracted to well it's like he's
hot i could be hot if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be oh pasta doesn't count
um no but you love pasta huh uh yeah i
love pasta but i if it had to be
official snack i'd say those lime chips
do you ever have those liners uh yes i
forget what the brand is i buy them all
the time lays i think it's like the big
butt they have a lime colored bag
they're extra large the whole bag yes
yeah they're yes i don't think they're
lazy no they're not they're more like
doritos styles yeah i think they're like
a frito brand yeah they're great well
but you love pasta pasta's your favorite
oh pasta is the best satisfying what
would be your go-to pasta or you have a
restaurant um no i don't have a go-to
restaurant i make a lot of pasta i just
throw things together i make great
pastas on the top of the stove i just
throw things together and it's always
good
the base is important yeah i used a lot
of clam juice i use uh bone broth oh
it's got a beef flavor you love my
grandma my grandma makes the best sauce
and the best gnocchi she does
i would never do it by hand yeah i buy
it yeah um what's your favorite movie of
all time
um i would say um
that's a good one dr zhivago oh yeah i
mean you probably never martial
such a such a great movie i have some
dark breakers like a rich
yeah yeah uh if you could if you had to
live somewhere else are these the
questions you ask everybody yes gee you
get anything exciting sometimes i often
get shamed for the movie question alec
baldwin was not happy to answer that uh
wouldn't you answer it well he did but
he was um
his point was like yeah i can't just one
yeah but he probably sees a lot more
movies than i do yeah um if you had to
live somewhere else where would it be i
guess maybe utah no no if i was
somewhere else anywhere that there's a
beach in the ocean i mean there's
something wonderful about being near the
ocean that makes almost anybody
makes them happier yeah you feel one
with whatever uh what who's your uh
favorite muppet do you have a muppet
that you really identify i've never
watched them obviously i couldn't help
you with that one okay um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
probably mother teresa
and now maybe even a godfather because
it sounds like a round out the party
nice yeah
if he's as good as you said he was you
may have been exaggerating no no he was
a good man dead or alive and probably um
my grandmother's mother to see what it
was like in
19 in 1880 i guess that would be about
when she was a young girl
in ireland uh no in new york city new
york just to see what what
like just to see what it was like yeah
yeah um if you could have a superpower
what would it be
um that's a good one a superpower
oh i would be 21 again yeah yeah okay i
want to poke myself with and i'm 21 all
over again well i also have that takes
care of the uh the next i swear to god
the next one was if you could be one age
for the rest of your life physically
what would it be no we're so great at
21. right i had three guys that wanted
to date me
and they were totally different
there was ramon simone no no he was a
little bit late he was at 23. 21
i had the uh god i remember one of the
remotes i know i had short sean
[Laughter]
who was actually very tall but he told
me whether it was true or not he was
half american indian and he would stand
on a box and neck with me for hours now
he was hot
then i had rocky rockiano from lodi rock
and he played these games yeah he played
the drums but the best part about him i
never knew what the good part about
playing the drums were and he had a big
drum set in his basement with he has
three three brothers big like him big
guy and he said come over here and stop
my laugh while i play the drums that was
fun and well rhythm he must have had
good rhythm yeah and then i had dennis
ryan oh he sat on his lap while he
played the drums yeah it was great weird
yeah right i was scared i never saw him
again i i figured
i mean this was gonna lead nowhere good
that was a short romance okay and then i
had shorter than short challenges
now picture this how many girls at that
age have three guys that can't wait to
get together with you but you're you
know you're looking good and you've got
a brain i wasn't that sick i i was
average and not that sexy come on i
don't know sure john would say otherwise
on his and don't you want to hear about
the third guy don't leave me on the
cliff like this no nothing heavy okay so
i had dennis ryan dennis ryan and the
great thing about dennis ryan is he was
he wrote me poetry and he sang to me
and that is very sexy to 21 year old
girl yeah sure he had lips and he was a
good kisser
did rocky rockiano not have full lips i
never got that far
right on that lap
scared me to death don't you wish you
could read some of dennis ryan's poetry
now at the time it was probably like he
was like
you know byron yeah but anyway he became
my first boyfriend you know why because
he went beyond the poetry what he did
was
for the seven days of christmas you know
that famous song right it's two turtle
doves
well what he did is by hand
you say this is a little odd for a man
but he was a sweetheart he made me all
those turtle doves all those ladies
dancing by hand and gave me the gifts on
christmas eve oh that's kind of what a
romance that's both odd and romantic
yeah what did he make them out of uh all
different things really he had a couple
of things made out of those hook rugs oh
my god the theme but he did it in
quantity that's really cool oh he was so
charming so he became my boyfriend i
thought he was the best pick for a
husband but then he didn't propose and i
moved on oh my god i'm trying to
remember all those gifts now uh
the best one was the white birds
whatever they i guess those would be the
dogs turtledoves yeah three three maids
uh three amazing milking milken how do
you do that he had like these little um
like uh what were were they almost like
christmas ornaments uh-huh and he made
little caps and had them in their hands
for little barrels so creative dan is
trying i wonder if he's listening that's
cool maybe he is i met him about 10
years ago he said let's get together and
i thought to myself oh get together with
my first love that's always interesting
yeah yeah i'm married i asked bill's
permission he said what do i care about
i'm a rock yeah
uh better dennis does it than me i get
to stay home
people from your past must be really
um
their reaction to your success must be
one of
surprise i wouldn't know i don't hear
from them i never hear from any of those
guys anymore
however when i gave myself my 70th
birthday party and threw myself a few
funeral and shocked my friends because i
was laying in a coffin when they came in
coffin isn't going coughing coffin yeah
it's in new jersey coming out
um i heard
we got a lot of publicity we're not
intended on that because most people
don't kill themselves on their birthday
no but we got so much publicity i must
have heard from
i would say dozens of people i hate from
my hometown yeah high school it's funny
what brings people back in your life
right well that's what that you know
i've heard of this before my neighbor in
massachusetts did this in fact a friend
of his did this had a funeral for
themselves oh my god i thought it was
the only one oh no well i'm sorry copied
me when did that happen a couple years
ago he was eight in his eighties yeah
but i thought it was such a great idea
um because you get to actually bless
yeah you did it when you were 70. 70
last year wow wow that's kind of nice
i'm not doing anything this year oh for
your funeral
um uh if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what what animal would
you want to come back as um i'd probably
want to come as uh
my husband's dog oh bill's because he
just pets that dog all day long you get
the affection from bill finally yeah
finally um would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny
oh unattractive it's easy because people
love funny people yeah yeah they don't
know what they look like right yeah yeah
you you know ugly person makes your life
worse because you got to look at them a
funny person makes your life better
because they make you laugh i ate grape
i never thought of it that way but i
agree uh which golden girl and i asked
everyone this which is a crazy question
you'll like this one which golden girl
do you most identify with this is a new
one dorothy blanche rose or sophia and
just to remind our audience dorothy was
um be arthur kind of the more alpha uh
blanche was real mcclanahan the sassier
saltier one and rose was betty white who
was the kind of slightly more dim-witted
but lovable and sophia was a style yeti
who was everybody picks rose come on uh
really you think i think so dim-witted
and charming not threatening and good to
hang out with and you don't even have to
think too hard of course she's the best
one yeah but which one do you identify
with oh yeah
i'd rather hang out with
blanche i think maybe i don't know hmm
you know i don't identify with any of
them they're all old
well that's good
that's true i thought of that uh really
quick dogs are cats
oh come on you're okay cats dogs dogs
i just said
people are into cats i don't either but
some people love them they do and you
can't say anything wrong against them or
any way beetles are rolling stones
for dancing the rolling stones mick
jagger can really move his ass yeah for
beautiful melodies and quantity and
quality is so much variety of course the
beatles that was the right answer and do
you ever think about uh your i mean this
is a morbid question but we've been
slightly morbid on the show about your
legacy about what you would want how you
would want to be remembered
oh god no i don't think about that but i
think the guy who had the best idea what
was that irish guy recently they put him
in the ground
and as they put the dirt on top all of
his grandchildren and family members
were standing around he had arranged a
recording saying hey let me out i heard
about this that's fabulous that's funny
and the kids started laughing first it
seems religious but the kids started
laughing first really and then it ripped
up the line but can i tell you wouldn't
that be great it would be great
she was great
i know did anybody cry at your fake
funeral
um no you'd be surprised at what people
did to me in that coffin in my fake
funeral i got french kisses oh whoa
oh so you actually laid in the coffin
dead yeah for 45 minutes
that's crazy now the best part was no
one expected that they thought they were
giving me a surprise parting waiting for
me to walk in my apartment but you
caught wind of it uh no no i had planned
the surprise on them i reversed it and
so when they walked into my living room
they almost had heart attacks because i
was dead in my coffin well you talked
about not feeling totally satisfied when
you plan things when you plan parties
things don't always go right you must
have been that one was a good one yeah
yeah no doubt about it even my doorman
the next morning showed me what what's
that website where they tell you when
you when you were born when you die he
showed me i was dead what oh wikipedia
wikipedia i was dead for one day on
wikipedia that's so funny oh cause it
was in the press it was in the no it
wasn't it hadn't even appeared in the
press by the next morning i was dead in
wikipedia i don't know how they get
their information oh my god when people
were doing that stuff to you in the
coffin did you giggle did you laugh or
do you think
do you ever play games at your parties
like uh social you know like um like a
catchphrase or something like that no no
no no i usually have theme parties i
love theme parties because it gets
people in the mood you get the benefit
of the party uh month before because
people are anticipating you're planning
the planet they plan it yeah it's it's a
lot more fun though you must like
halloween uh not so much you know why
because orange and black are ugly colors
to decorate with so i've never been able
to pull off a halloween party that my
heart was in oh that's interesting and
it's expected halloween you know i don't
know yeah oh okay well um
well you would speaking of being
expected this was totally unexpected i
did not know of course i had
did you expect i thought you'd be more
business oriented and kind of talk
business i don't know i know i know but
like
but i associate that with like
kind of more boring you know and not as
personable and lighthearted and animated
so you've really um you'd make a great
business man i'll tell you why because
you have the two traits that every great
business person has if you're starting
your own business i'm not talking
working for a big corporation yeah you
got to be a yes man to a degree and do
what you're supposed to do but if you're
starting a business the only thing
that's really important is that you have
people skills and you convince people to
come and have a good time
if you could get people to believe hey
come on over here this is good you're
going to do well here and you really
believe it you'll sell people on it
and if you get along with people they'll
stay with you that's all businesses i
mean it's it's it almost needs a new
label if you have your own business it
shouldn't be called business should we
call my party or my house or something
oh that's interesting i like that do it
a little more you're gonna find people
are very fascinating entrepreneurs well
you have been and this has been so
enlightening and fun and and uh again
unexpected and i'm i'm so happy we did
those i can't look at you without
thinking of blues clues i'm sorry you
look so much like that guy that's okay
well we should talk about it okay we'll
talk about i shouldn't because now i'm
gonna go on your show yeah yeah yeah and
uh you can ask me what's going on start
with that favorite emoji is annoying me
you know okay kind of thing let's let's
do it i'm going to
urinate and have a banana not at the
same time
that's disgusting with the banana
parsley
[Music]
so so
that happened that happened i you know
when i'm having memories now of um when
we took the picture afterwards barbara
insisted i heard this
and i turned around and she was patting
her lap she was sitting down and she
wanted me like and i was like
a little thrown by it she goes come on
when you sit on her yeah sit on her lap
it was very scary
yeah sherry we talked to jerry our
friend jerry o'connell the other day uh
and again he's one of our friends we
might check in with on a special episode
um which is not this but yeah barbara
wanted me to sit on her lap did you of
course what
what do you mean she wanted me to did
you
hurt her
no but i was of course did you put all
your weight on her i did at one point i
had to i was in like the swivel chair
there was no with no arm rests um
or
it was hard for me to like relieve any
of my weight did you protest at all
before yeah of course are you sure yeah
i did all the
things you're supposed to do
all the like normal social etiquette
things when somebody asks you to sit on
their lap i it's i think i remember the
last time someone's asked me to sit on
their lap probably santa claus maybe
last year
oh yeah we did them all he uh actually
remember we did i sat on santa's lap so
did i that's right you don't both have
to sit on santa's lap adults
um oh no i didn't do it as an adult oh i
did it last year oh you did when we went
to that uh that
winter wonderland thing you did yeah and
he got last year it was like three
months ago he got creepy with your
girlfriend he did he got creepy with you
yeah yeah anyway uh so you sat on her
lap and it sat on her lap her she must
be very fit i kept checking in with her
are you sure this okay we were taking a
lot of how long did you sit up oh
20 seconds 30. what yeah the time
she must be very strong what do you
think of now when you think of 30
seconds
uh washington yes
right away i've been washing my hands i
would say
15 to 20 times a day me too about that
maybe maybe 20. but in in fairness i
sing to 30 every time i watch oh in my
head you know what i do one two three
four five oh i go backwards i go 30 29
28 27 but i've been doing that uh
not to brag but i've been doing that
before this all happened i was always
into washing my hands and people would
always often tease me about being
germaphobic or oh you don't like shaking
hands you know i would get judgment
anyway so that interview was very
interesting oh yeah a lot of pearls of
wisdom she was very sassy she was sassy
was right that's what the whole sitting
on the lap thing was that makes sense
doesn't that make yeah yeah she seems
like someone who would want a grown man
to sit on her lap when i picture when i
first get
doesn't she yeah especially a grown man
who weighs like 130 pounds i know well
that's the thing it was a little
emasculating when i was like am i you
sure i'm not hurting you and she's like
no no it's fine you're fine i barely
know you're on me you know it's
interesting that she was such a bad
student isn't that crazy and i and i was
wondering when she was saying that i was
wondering i wonder what kind of bad
student and then as i was wondering that
she said i couldn't do
something she said something like i
couldn't do i couldn't read or or do
numbers
i was like read or do numbers that's
like that's really big that's that's all
of it
that's like being a baseball player
being like except i can't throw her or
hit
i can't field her yeah uh that yeah it's
so it's amazing that she was able to
overcome that i know and it really it
goes to show you how that determination
not only determination but different
types of intelligence
like when we were kids it was always
book smart and street smart those are
the two
you know general
terms about intelligence but now we know
that there's so many more there's like
kinetic intelligence and there's so many
different types of intelligences also
interesting that she was
not only a bad student but ridiculed
for it and i think as a result of that
she was able to
kind of develop this acumen and strive
for yeah yeah and for talking and yeah
and
um doing things that are that were
outside of the traditional
you hear that all the time uh isn't that
isn't that a familiar
story it is in a way um but it reminds
me a little bit of bill burr struggle
like in order people who are very
successful tend to have had a real
struggle to overcome
whereas someone who's just handed
everything in life
they may maintain the money that their
parents handed down to them sure but
will they have the drive to achieve
something
that they otherwise wouldn't have yeah
it's it's like it's cultivating a a will
overcome yes determination yeah she
really has that in spades
um
who knew how traumatic dancing with the
stars was
oh my god i know
crazy isn't that nuts i'm a little
surprised she admitted all that i kept
like checking in i know i'm i i've never
heard that maybe is that a known thing i
don't know
it's that and it's also
like abc disney just like cloak and
dagger [ __ ] they wouldn't even let her
change into her
other outfit
i kept checking in with her face you
know because i because i don't i'm just
meeting her for the first time and
i she was she had a very good sense of
humor and she was very i thought maybe
she was just being dry and she was being
sarcastic uh but but i think she that
was all sincere
it's crazy crazy they made her get on
the plane alone
oh it's nuts it's nuts
i mean i guess that show is so popular
that they need to be it is yeah
god but both but to not let her drop her
off her apartment you know
that makes you wonder what they do with
the bachelors and the bachelorettes when
they
um when that when they end up with
somebody if they end up with somebody
yeah as you all know this last season
that did not happen spoiler alert she
also has a podcast by the way we should
mention oh yes called
888. i was on it yeah did i tell you
about it no no i didn't tell you what
you she took she did it
yeah yeah well she does a tarot card
reading i mean which always has scared
me um
i had a friend years ago who always was
trying to get me to go do tarot card
readings and i always resisted um and
she read my fortune and something she
told me was
uh with the tarot cards was actually
really alarming oh you did tell me this
i told you um
i suppose i should tell everyone she she
turned the card over and she said oh and
her face totally changed
oh
wow that's uh oh that's a
i said what you know what does that mean
she's like well that's your and it was a
devil it was like a devil character with
like a crazy tongue and it was
judging by her reaction seemed very
naughty and it was about she said
did something
really drastic happen between your
parents when you were a kid
i really wish you weren't reminding me
of this because it makes me very
uncomfortable i know and everything else
she'd been here's the worst part
everything else she'd been saying was
like pretty accurate and i was like yes
yes and then she drops this bomb about
something maybe happening and i think it
was of like
like an erotic nature oh god
please
please sorry but it's
yeah and she she seemed she didn't take
it back or walk it back she was she i
was really obviously like incredulous
and
and she was like yeah well that's what
it's that's what it says
she said you might want to ask them
so i i have you asked no um she at one
point she said that people take
advantage of her openness
and she says uh and she said you know i
let everyone in i let everyone in every
tom dick and harry and under your breath
you
uh
another butthead moment i've been having
some you've been having a lot of fun at
the moment you know i was watching uh
david muir um 2020 he does i'm very
impressed by him oh i thought you were
gonna say i'm impressed that you
pronounced his name right
did that it's not that i was have to do
that because i was very sure of it i
think it's
wrong mirror muir woods oh it is mirror
i think so but david muir last night on
uh now it's sounding like you're
pronouncing it wrong
demure
david muir
uh said last night he was doing a piece
on um
this brilliant doctor and her name was
dr b-e-a-v-i-s
yeah it really made me laugh i was just
picturing like if beavis's mom was like
this really impressive
person yeah and he's like she's just
yeah but she spent all her time being
impressive in like the medical world and
kind of neglected him so he was always
home with butt head that's funny dr
beavis that's funny uh your mom's
your mom is really smart uh it's crazy
that she grew up with ten with nine
siblings ten kids
and every time dick and harry is fine
that is funny because dick is so close
to harry
and like but back in the day when that
expression was i know it was widely
totally innocent those were the most
popular names that that's why
like
dick and james now you'd say every
john noah and
uh
brittany and tyler or something yeah
it's gonna be men right boys it doesn't
have to be that's true it doesn't have
to be anymore yeah time's up
or is that time's up or is that just
like times different times different
yeah 20 20. yeah fluid uh so lots of
siblings
and it taught her
how to negotiate with people and it's
interesting the correlation she drew
between
her role and her family growing up
having to be a broker
being a middle child of 10
and
and uh what she does in her career
having a broker of these real estate
deals how it's how connected that is
that's true yeah it really is and she
she expressed that yeah i mean it was um
having to deal with people being in the
middle she seemed like the
not the peacemaker but it's sort of yeah
yeah and also i always wondered about
shark tank because i really like that
show and i often wonder when they do
decide to invest
how much of it is based on
the idea itself
versus the person who's pitching the
idea
i always figured it was more about the
person
than the invention itself that's what
she said
and oh you did i wouldn't have thought
that i always thought that because
well you don't watch the show very often
but but it always seems like there's
some really obnoxious
people yeah who often have
really good ideas and
they the sharks tend to treat them
harshly and they kind of click they like
them yeah they call out their
uh arrogance yeah or whatever it's good
to uh
that she clarified that and i'm glad
that they do that well i find that in
just in the business people that i
interact with on a very like base
level i always prefer dealing with
people that you like more and and that
you that have things that you value that
aren't necessarily like business acumen
you know maybe that's why i've um
i i'm susceptible to like con artists
you know like yeah i once was i mean
speaking of barbara that barbara had
this happened to her lately i was oh
yeah he was taken in but you didn't talk
about that no i didn't because i didn't
well i should say i was um so we should
say what happened yeah so uh years ago i
was um now with you with her oh well
with me i was i had i got involved in
this like it was like a real estate scam
basically basically uh i
bought a house in vegas it's a long
story i got involved with this grifter
and his mother and
he turned out to be a
meth addict anyway i was going to bring
this up uh the day before we i did the
interview this was all over the news
that barbara had been taken in by a
confidence scam uh herself on an email
scam and she had been conned out of like
four hundred thousand dollars
yeah
crazy and she didn't seem that upset by
it right
no but then i found out later that she i
think she got her money back oh really i
think that there was a happy end to the
style
yeah
um i like the story she told about when
she first started her
company
she spent she had like a thousand
dollars twelve hundred dollars or
something and she went out and bought a
nice like a fancy coat yeah that's
something i wouldn't do but it but it
was shrewd
because she looked because it projected
an air of
uh professionalism yes um wealth i guess
that's true success so you don't think
she was doing it because she liked the
jacket and she always wanted a jacket
like that and it was just a happy
accident that it happened to project a
certain you think that was deliberate
you think that was part of her choice
she made it sound deliberate yeah yeah
and i have no reason not to believe her
yeah that's true
that's what makes her uh a good
businesswoman also because
uh when she was talking about not being
able to relax easily
and that her idea of
relaxing is like planning a party yeah
and she's very very active yeah i think
that type of personality
is
what you need and i've seen versions of
this on the show before people who
become very very successful
um
tend to
not be able to
slow down very much which is in her
character to constantly be
doing things and moving it's interesting
it's like an actual shark
yeah i mean that's what sharks can't
stop uh moving they died oh interesting
yeah but she's a benevolent shark
because oh yeah for sure she was saying
like a nurse shark she was saying that
on the show they
want her to
they want all of them to
ramp up their sharkness oh yeah for the
show yeah but her natural demeanor and
her natural personality is not uh nearly
as sharkish which i found interesting
and i can tell by the interview her
persona on the show is quite different
from
it is how much yeah i thought so you
know it's similar to what bobby burke
said bobby burke of uh queer eye um he
said that the producers in the beginning
of that
series they wanted them to
kind of be
a little bit more
sassy and um judgmental um
and yeah interesting makes sense she was
somewhat offended by the golden girls
question but it wasn't
it was nothing to do with the fact that
no one is an older woman no uh you're
asking everyone that question i know but
now i'm wondering should i not ask older
women that you should ask everyone that
question i think it's a really good
question
and i would say she's a blanche
yeah
she's a black she likes a party she's
sassy oh yeah for sure she's a blanche
100 she's totally yes you're both
blanched she's like a true blanche well
she's a blanche you're a blanche rose a
little bit i think i have a little
sophia yeah you keep saying that yeah
you know who has sophia is uh our
grandmother yeah our grandmother's
always reminded me of sophia in many
ways she's like little she's like a
frizzy head
you know and she says we just talked to
her
you concluded the interview by saying
i'm gonna urinate and have a banana i
didn't say that you sure did
at the same time you go well i'm gonna
go urinate and have a banana
and i do remember it was impossible not
to picture it
so thanks for that did you when you
pictured it was i doing at the same time
you were standing up eating a banana and
peeing
you know i actually think if i ate a
banana while peeing i would pee sitting
down
i hope so
what do you mean why
because what's your thought process what
why do you say that
because it's more controlled yeah
whereas if you're standing up you have
to have you have control you have to be
more focused on what you're doing with
the urinating yeah
and eating the banana do you ever
whereas if you're sitting down then
everything is kind of underneath the
cylinder so it feels a little bit more
hygienic yeah if you're eating the
banana then what's the last time you
peed with your pants totally down down
or off uh down like you have them on and
you're planning on putting them back on
but you just take them all the way down
like little kid style we've talked about
this before i don't do that yeah but
there's something about it i do it every
once in a while all the way to the
ground yeah and i always get a little
like it's kind of nice just like a
little bit of like
nostalgia like the way it used to be
like an innocent time let's read a
letter okay
this is from morgan l subject uh oh i'm
sorry christian
i'm so curious hi justin hi christian
i've been a shorty from the start and
have to say you bring joy to my tuesdays
now
huge fan emotionally not physically okay
i'll jump right in and put the derek
cheater hypothesis to rest okay so if
you've been listening for the last
couple of weeks we've been talking about
uh whether or not christian can uh bat
better or as well as derek jeter can
with it christian with his dominant hand
derek jeter with his lesser hand
i listened to life is short while
working and due to the coronavirus i've
been working from home my boyfriend was
interested in listening to an episode so
we listened to that weeks with bill nye
i just pictured like the boyfriend being
like i want to hear what this is all
about and like
what are these guys yeah look there's
two guys you listen to
uh and he packed the letter while you
guys were discussing christian's
dominant batting hand versus derek
cheater's weaker hand vj
my boyfriend the the letter v and j
jumps up and shouts into the speaker no
way christian derek is a switch hitter
whoa
i'm sorry christian i was on your side
but apparently derek is on both huh it
was great to see vijay laughing and
invested that is nice but sad to see
christian's hopes and dreams crumble
before me thought i'd share the news
well thank you for doing that morgan i'd
like to also add again how much joy you
two bring to my week
i look forward to pressing play no
matter what the guest and hearing the
brother banter and genuine kindness come
through thank you both thank you morgan
favorite episode jennifer goodwin ah i
laughed and cried my way through
favorite snack pla plantain chips
jamaican jerk if you can stand the spice
i like plantain chips happy quarantining
with a loving heart morgan
that is really nice uh and
educational
so well what do you think of that i'll
tell you what i mean about that first of
all i also love plantain chips veg
second of all i'm glad vijay is having a
good time
and yeah me too and i'm glad he was
invested in the show yeah but there's a
butt coming make an opinion but he
happens to be wrong
derek jeter is not a switch hitter he's
a right-handed hitter
and maybe vj has some inside information
that uh
where he knows that yeah but harry peter
can also competently bat from the left
side but wow i've never heard of that
what this is you know here's the weird
part about this is that uh morgan
describes vijay as jumping up and
shouting into the speaker she even
capitalizes his quote no way christian
derek is a switch hitter it's weird to
do that incredible incredulous and he's
wrong
yeah i wonder who he's confusing derek
jeter with i wonder if he's now googling
it i wonder if he's still listening
first of all i hope he is i mean here's
the thing here's also we're just happy
he's listening yeah but he's wrong
here's the thing if derek jeter
is even like remotely competent batting
from his left side even if he's like
right five percent as good at batting
left-handed as he is right-handed which
is very possible very probable in fact
then he's a much better hitter than than
i am from my dominant side i'm i was
just holding out the possibility that if
he happens to be
extremely right right-handed dominant
then there's a chance and that i could
you know and not to rehash what we
talked about last week but i still think
uh it's true that if he is that much
better at one hand than the other there
would exist footage of he of him being
that
bad
at his lesser hand i think that's a
stupid argument okay well i continue to
think that's a stupid argument well uh
why
because there'd be footage of that if he
was that time he was embarrassed by that
he wouldn't do it with the camera going
he his friend would have done it or some
fan like that's a spring training would
have that videotape i mean possibly but
that's a major leap
anyway anyway thanks um morgan yeah
thanks morgan and vijay even though
you're wrong i wonder if morgan calls
vijay veej maybe i would would
definitely would thanks vij and thanks
to our guest barbara corker oh thanks
bart she is awesome she you know she
asked me to do something on instagram
today um
to you know there are all those like
instagram challenges she wanted me to do
a baby channel baby photo challenge oh
you should do it just really really fun
to follow on instagram um oh my do you
hear that my stomach yeah uh anyway
thanks
say thanks to all the shorties and
hopefully new shorty feeds uh and we'll
talk to you guys soon and hope you are
keeping your sanity during this insane
time
and uh well we'll check in soon check in
uh hopefully sooner than a week um with
this a new special episode but uh good
luck everyone yeah stay safe stay
healthy
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh life is short is hosted by me justin
long a quarantine justin long
and produced by and also quarantined
christian long
as well by a quarantined meghan monaco
senior producer is quarantined michelle
miche lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
hopefully quarantined as well also
probably quarantined executive producers
marshall louis and hernan lopez
for wondering
[Music]
wow
wow
wow i said a prayer last night
i said lord please
please guide
peter today and guide madison to see
where they're at in this relationship
because wow
you have a gem waiting for you
who is madly head over heels in love
with you and won't question you put her
there for you
i think god has answered my prayers
and
put the right person this is nuts
but you know maybe deep in your heart
but you knew that
because of she's scary we're already
surrounding the situation
yeah she's a sinister sweet girl lovely
girl that hannah ann is an angel on
earth
and i want him to make the right choice
i love you so much oh
out religious madison publicly
[Music]
she i didn't think she said she's like
i'm spiritual but i'm not like you yeah
whoa she's dark she's scary that was
crazy do you hear the
girl see that girl mouth she goes that
was crazy
that was crazy
you